this is joe navarro former fbi agent spy
catcher expert on non-verbal
communication and the author of 13 books
including the international bestseller
what everybody is saying today this
expert on all things body language is
going to be taking a look at a case from
rockstar's detective classic l.a noir
i'm looking at him straddling this naked
body and that would in no way ever take
place nowadays if you want to see more
of joe or his takes on investigatory
video games then be sure to support him
by following him on twitter and picking
up one of his fascinating books link to
those in the description below now it's
over to joe
[Music]
[Music]
there she is
as i look at the investigators
and uh and i i see obviously how things
have have uh have changed over the years
you notice how everybody's in close
proximity and they're walking right up
to the body there's no way nowadays that
all of a sudden you would have all these
investigators just stepping all over the
evidence
any defense attorney nowadays would
immediately
contest any evidence collected from the
crime scene did you miss any evidence
well how would you know you were
standing all over it
talk me through it mal severely battered
on display
footprints would indicate that she has
been stomped
size of the footprints would seem to
indicate a smallish men's shoe you mind
if i examine the body you might guess
[Music]
this this is interesting i'm looking at
him straddling this naked body and that
just
would in no way
ever take place
nowadays usually and i've worked
many homicides
as an fbi agent and having worked these
you know the first thing you you learn
is that
you cordon off at least 30 40 feet and
you work your way inward i remember
taking
pieces of uh two by four and oftentimes
i would lay these down so i would have a
a walkway to the victim in case there
was any evidence underneath that that i
might miss at a distance
as i'm watching you you notice that um
he's uh touching her face i mean you
just definitely don't touch her body
defense attorney would uh would
attack that immediately if you're going
to get this close to the body the first
thing you want to do also is you want to
put paper bags around the hands and then
you seal it with tape and what that does
is it preserves any evidence that may be
in the hands
it preserves any evidence that is in the
fingernails this is one of those points
where you could literally spend a day in
class
just analyzing uh you know
what can be done what should be done and
what should not be done certainly
straddling the victim shouldn't be done
[Applause]
oh we have a name you notice he's
handling the purse without gloves you
certainly wouldn't handle it with your
uh with your own hands because there's a
good likelihood that a suspect may
likewise have touched the purse and
there may be some
evidence there
[Music]
[Music]
phelps and galloway lapd
is your father home he'll be home soon
he's been out looking for mommy
what's your name miss
one of the things that you learn about
interviewing is that
with children
in particular you really shouldn't stand
that close to them the minute you begin
to violate their space
they they feel insecure so if we were
doing this
today
we would knock on the door and
actually take a step back allow the
child to open the door
but not move any closer to them the
other thing that we see with both
investigators
you notice that
they both furrow their it's called the
glabella
one of the problems with the display on
the part of the officers
is that from the time that a child is
about 11 months old they already know
that the furrowed glabella represents
that something's not right or that
there's an issue and
that affects the interview so one of the
things that you want to do is not look
like these two guys
[Music]
[Music]
work boots
size eights they have a a shoe with a
similar pattern that we've seen before
uh at the crime scene
uh conveniently the uh
the number eight is there and those are
great that's
that's uh that's what you're uh you're
looking for but you also have to
remember that um the house of a
potential suspect is also a a potential
uh crime scene and so you know walking
about and uh and picking up things
that's something you also don't don't do
obviously you want to protect it but you
also want to photograph
where exactly you found that shoe
in this case you you know you know that
it's uh on the floor but it's under a
window you could have a defense attorney
said well is it possible that my client
is being framed and somebody dropped
them there so you have to uh
remember that eventually all this goes
before
a trier of the facts
when did you last see your mother
yesterday afternoon
i went to a dance at belmont high
mommy was supposed to pick me up but she
didn't show so what did you do then i
was upset
daddy came instead
it's not about whether you believe what
she's saying is truthful uh it's
doubtful it's a lie those are actually
the wrong questions you have to remember
that whatever anybody says whether they
are truthful or lying whether it's a
victim or a suspect you have to go out
and corroborate that information because
if you don't
defense is going to bring it up you as a
police officer may say oh yeah this this
young lady is being truthful and you you
buy everything she says but if you don't
go out and test it and validate it
defense attorney
is gonna go out and he's gonna or she's
gonna talk to witnesses and other people
who might that might discredit her and
this is something that people fail to
understand because they watch television
and they've sort of been indoctrinated
into
into how it's done so we have to
corroborate everything that in this case
she says and everything that a potential
suspect says
hey
what gives
daddy the police over here
i'll talk to him how do you pull me go
to your room young lady
she's not even out of school you can't
come in here interrogating her like
she's her wife was found murdered this
morning
found
what
but she only
[Music]
one of the things as investigators that
we look for is what is the initial
response of of someone when you tell
them uh someone as has uh has been found
dead did they display shock the freeze
response did they cover their mouth and
certainly anything they say um
this falls under
the the rule that uh
the surprises
um cause us to to utter things that are
very honest because
uh we don't have time to process it so i
would go back and listen to every single
little word that he says
what size shoe do you wear mr mueller
why do you ask
it's routine sir simple process of
elimination
nines i think
um i'm getting old but i pretty much
know what shoe size i wear and he's
giving himself a little bit of leeway a
defense attorney
would say no he gave a perfect answer he
said nine i think could it have been
eight he was never asked
why are you lying to me mr muller
there's no need to say why are you lying
you've got the facts you've got the size
8 shoe you're going to collect it as
evidence hopefully it was in plain sight
you were welcomed into the house so you
can seize it the minute you say why are
you lying to me you put people on the uh
on the defensive you phoned in a missing
person's report this morning
yeah that's right uh
my wife didn't come home last night she
left around
she left around 9 30.
michelle was out of dance she called me
to let me know that dj didn't turn up
the creators have uh have given us an
opportunity to examine a body language
you see the narrowing of the eyebrows
uh squinting of the eyes you see the
more compression of the lips the little
corners of the mouth
are called the commissures and you see
the commissures are slightly pinched so
he's bothered by something but what we
can't say is what he's bothered by
because he may be bothered by the
questions that are being asked he may be
bothered
by the attitude of
one or both of the officers
i know about the golden butterfly hugo
and how you bought your wife off the
last time you heard her
she liked to spend money all right
dresses
jewelry her hair drove me goddamn crazy
do i look like a rockefeller
nobody likes a cheapskate hugo
getting hostile with us is a very bad
idea hugo i'm no murderer
the detective says don't get uh don't
get hostile with us
you should go to some of the neighbors i
used to go into you see some things here
that um that that speak to
um
the the frailty of
the
interview process yeah when you're
talking about a homicide interview
um
minimum you're probably talking three to
four hours this is not the time to make
accusations this is still the fact
collecting uh phase you got to be
kidding me phelps put the cuffs on him
this is an outrage i didn't kill my wife
your daughter is in the next room
mueller so i'm giving you a break don't
make me change my mind and don't make me
come looking for you
wait a minute
your best piece of evidence is that shoe
and you just walked away from the best
piece of evidence and uh and you didn't
seize it
[Music]
[Applause]
why did you burn your shoes hugo
because i knew you'd never believe me
believe one
it's rabbit's blood
the guy at work brought him in and i
helped him skin them
we don't have the report from the lab
which would show that that is
blood from a rabbit you have to attack
it from the perspective of how would a
defense attorney attack this
what's missing here what could be argued
are there weaknesses in the case
yes there's a lot more evidence that
needs to be collected every neighbor
needs to be talked to blood needs to be
tested there's a lot of strengths and
and there's a lot of weaknesses in in
the case but could you go to a court and
say do
we have probable cause to her arrest
i would say obviously yes
you know i i think eleanor
a a a pretty good job of representing
the true genre of that time period it it
certainly could be used
for training
because you you can you can use it to
look for you know are we looking at
crimping up the lips are we looking at
draw displacement i'd like to see more
of the interview process
of the the back and forth
that that can go on
um and especially the the body language
of both the the suspect and the
investigator
because what the investigator does
non-verbally affects
um the the suspect but really very
interesting and uh and and very well
done representing that um that time
period
[Music]
you